[Music]
China is supposedly modernizing and
becoming a global superpower but in
other ways it still remains seriously
medieval health officials there have
just confirmed the fourth incident this
month of plague as in V plague the
plague that killed half of Europe in the
Middle Ages how does the plague spread
and is it heading here dr. mark Siegel
is a fox medical contributor and he
joins us now we will we're laughing
about it but the three big pandemics of
the plague since the 14th century have
all come from this part of the world and
the reason for that and we're not really
laughing about this point the Chinese
government even though they've created a
Centers for Disease Control that's
patterned after our own where they
literally track cases and they know
who's sick they don't know how to inform
the world about this they suppress it on
social media they delete their tweets
where they say hey someone has the
plague they don't tell the World Health
Organization for weeks as you were
mentioning this led to an outbreak of a
virus called SARS in 2003 that spread to
over 30 countries I'm worried about that
happening with a plane now they have
checkpoints on the roads
can you imagine you're driving along the
road and they're stopping you to see if
you have a plague or where you go to an
airport and they're checking your
temperature it's spreading panic in
China right now but isn't this something
to do with the so called one country two
systems' things because as with SARS and
presumably it could happen with the
plague some some guy in upcountry rural
China eats the wrong Marmot and then his
aunt goes to visit her cousin in Hong
Kong and one of them happens to be
standing in the elevator at the
Intercontinental and the businessman
who's staying there gets on a flight to
Cape Town or New York or Paris and
that's how it spreads
exactly right mark you could be working
for the CDC let me tell you it's a
bacteria and it lives in rodents and
rodents around the world still carry
this bacteria but unfortunately in parts
of China they're eating it raw also
fleas on the sir
of these varmints right then spread it
to humans so fleas hopping from rats to
humans that's why it was so deadly in
Europe because they had a problem with
all of the rats now with Chinese
government right now is trying to kill
all the rodents and the fleas and
they're trying to control it that way
which is a probably a good idea but the
fear worries me because you know what
happens when you get the plague if it
isn't treated fast enough with
antibiotics it develops a long form man
pneumonic plague can spread by literally
coughing it on to somebody so and has a
much and has a much higher death rate
right a percent and two of the people
that have had it this month have had
this version if they got on a plane
god forbid came to New York you could
see a case well before anyone invented
air travel in the nineteenth century the
last big pandemic started killing
members of the Chinese community in San
Francisco and Chester Arthur signed the
Chinese Exclusion Act which everyone
thinks he did now just because he was a
big horrible white racist but in fact it
was a health issue and he's feeling that
that that would not be politically
feasible at all today so do we just have
to trust a chance that nobody gets on
that plane no we need to be fighting
this point just as we're doing on the
show here it's not about you know one
society versus another or the color of
your skin it's about the risk to public
health and when you see a disease
reemerging even for cases in a month is
more than they ever have there and we're
going to see a lot more cases we need to
get the information out there it needs
to be at airports and people need to be
on the lookout fear spreads more disease
than any virus in any bacteria well
that's a cheerful note to end on
for this thing's we don't catch the
plague before Monday